all right hello everybody
hope everybody is doing well
so let's see
we've got 43 people here and elise is
there it's good to see you lisa
there's neil arriving all right we can
start with neil now
dirt poor robbins is there i'm gonna try
hard to
pay more attention to the chat hopefully
i can do that at some point
it's hard so there are a lot of
questions hey brad it's good to see brad
here
got my it feels uh comforting to know
that my crew is around
uh
yeah neil says reading chat is
impossible i don't know i watch some
youtubers and they do it it's amazing
it's like uh
i think it's probably like a skill
you're born with so
all right guys so there are so many
questions there is no there's no
way that i could get through these i
think there's like 50 questions it just
keeps getting more and more
at every uh every turn so shakey
raindrop says
they finally joined the facebook group
great yeah the facebook group has just
been
amazing it's just uh you know i'm so
grateful
to have all these people you know
at that level of discussion is it's
really wonderful to see that
and kind of continue on at that level
we also have all the articles that are
going up on the symbolic world
um jp masso just put up an article today
again
going deep into the miracle question
which is i think really important in
terms of
understanding how far we can go with
this
idea of emergence and emanation
so so the miracle question is really
interesting the video i did with jp on
that
was a lot of fun as well um
for those who are on on uh supporting me
somehow today i put up the patron
subscriber only video which was on
robinhood and i have to apologize
because i
instead of putting the video on um
unlisted i put it private and so all
these people went online and then
couldn't watch the video
so it has been fixed you could watch the
the
robin hood video and i'm sorry because
yeah these last few weeks have been
insane these last few days
we're supposed to move into our house
like in two weeks
at tops and uh nothing is it's like
construction is a crazy world
i feel sorry for all you who are in
construction it's just crazy
and so every evening i've been there
until like 9 10 at night trying to
finish
things up that i can do because i'm not
a construction guy but i'm trying to do
what i can
and my wife is just like you know she's
just totally tired of
dealing with all the details and stuff
so anyways that's my problem but that
looks that's why my hair is so dirty
look at that i need to take a shower
it's horrible
all right so so hopefully i will not be
i will not be insane in this this q a
today so
we'll go through everything is there
some other announcement that i wanted to
make yeah
guys make sure you you guys like i don't
forget that the
the clip channel just keeps going lisa
just keeps putting and uh
there's there are a few people involved
on the on the clip channel and so i just
want to say
uh to to just keep going and uh
subscribe there because
it's a lot of fun to watch these little
clips like even watching myself just
sometimes i
forget the things i say and so it sounds
like wait did i talk about this and i'm
like i watch a
i watch a um
i watch a little clip you know to to
remember what it is that i said
luckily i haven't caught myself saying
something that i think is completely
crazy
which could be which could totally which
could totally happen
um so yeah all right
okay so i think we need to
start
okay here we go so i am going to
start on the
let's start with the website
okay
all right here we go there's a lot of
questions
man stressing me out all right okay so
here we go
so m j v l m
j v i l i m i don't know how to say that
not using okay so according to frank
sheed in his theology insanity
genesis uses the verb create presumably
mean hebrew rather
than made only three instances when god
creates heaven and earth when he creates
man and when he creates sea monsters
she says that says man is created
because his soul is a fresh creation
says he has no idea why sea monsters are
created rather than made
uh do you um
i'm not sure i totally follow the
argument it's like i think it's kind of
dropping into my lap like this and i
don't know
exactly what i never heard that before
so i would have to check into it and see
because
i'm not sure exactly um
i'm not sure exactly whether it infers
in terms of the difference between
creating
and making so i would have to i would
have to look it up so sorry i don't have
a better answer for you on that
so another so mfp
rysl says
catholicism puts a lot of stress on the
statement that transubstantiation is
real and not symbolic
i know that you for you symbolic is not
opposite to real how do you then phrase
the reality
of the eucharist to make a distinction
that it is a reality and not just mere
play
you know i once heard a deacon say this
and i know that he was quoting another
theologian that i don't know where he
was getting it from
but i once heard a deacon in the
orthodox church say um
catholics believe that the that um
that the eucharist is real protestants
believe the eucharist is symbolic and
orthodox believe it is real because it
is symbolic
that is once you understand that reality
is symbolic that
it's it meaning is
is in what is the thing in which things
culminate logos is the things
in which things culminate then then you
can believe that it is
that it is absolutely real because it is
symbolic
it's not it's not just mere play it's
not but then
everything is like that all of reality
is symbolic and so
it's not like it's the exception it's
like the culmination of everything
um so that's the way that i see it
and so i really do believe that it is
truly the blood and body of christ
um but i would say most most orthodox
would believe that it is also
at the same time bread and wine that it
doesn't stop being bread and wine
that it is truly really the blood and
blood of
blood and body of christ um without
destroying the
elements or without sucking the elements
into
some other essence completely
that's the way i see it anyways
someone's going to catch me and tell me
that i'm
it's not right or being i mean heretical
which is possible
um man i feel like i'm giddy it's not
good it's not i'm not in a good space i
need to change the space i'm in
so it's the story of uh so plumage asks
is the story of joseph being played out
in christ
where he is written from the jews among
the foreigner but then
is revealed to be messiah to them at a
later time
i believe so sorry i think that the
story of joseph just has
so many jewels in it in terms of
understanding christ and i do think that
if we look
at on the on the large scale i think
that that's exactly what's happening
i think that um i think that
um the messiah saved the foreigner
first and while he's saving the
foreigner
then the jews cannot recognize him
and there's he seems like even
saint paul seems to refer to a mystery
in which in the end you know
this is going to flip or it's going to
turn and then
you know he'll be recognized so i think
that the story of joseph is really the
really good template to understand the
how christ
is acting in the world especially after
scripture like after the bible how
christ was given over to to was sold
to the foreigner uh in his case for 30
pieces of silver
by judah and then
basically since then he's been a captive
of
the stranger until something happens
until the end or something i don't know
all right so david flores says with
youtube's new terms tos
being unfriendly towards creators are
you planning on focusing on other
platforms for videos and so
look all my videos are being uploaded
automatically to bit shoot
and so there is a fail-safe there the
videos are all there
um i've been working in collaboration
with a company
called content safe you guys can check
it out if you're interested in that
they they've been kind of they kind of
have my back they're the people who are
also making my website
um they kind of have my back in the
sense that they make sure that all my
videos
that i that go up are saved on bit shoot
and they also even save them
on a hard drive so that if i if if
things go
haywire and i lose all my content then
they will be able to afford it to me and
so for a pretty reasonable price a month
they kind of offer that service so you
guys if you're interested in that check
it out
um it's definitely something that so if
things go really crazy with youtube then
there's [ __ ] shoot but
[ __ ] you did not good it's just not a
good platform it doesn't
it doesn't um the thing about youtube is
that
you can discover people through youtube
it's easy to discover others through
youtube it's harder to discover things
through
through [ __ ] but having said that it's
obvious that my channel is somehow
shadow banned several people have told
me that they don't get notifications
or that you know um paul vander clay
just today said
if i type the title of your discussion
with uh
rationality rules he said only his video
pops up in the search but your video
doesn't pop up and it's the same video
and so that's something that people have
mentioned and so you know if you
anyway so i mean i don't know how much
we can push youtube in terms of
making sure people are subscribed making
sure that they have the notifications on
um you know sharing the videos so that
the word gets out but we're kind of
bit shoots now know better like if i put
up my videos on [ __ ]
no one's gonna see them so it's it's
frustrating it's frustrating
on all platforms on twitter on facebook
i'm getting
now you know i've started to have
warnings on my facebook post
and someone saw also a warning on my
youtube channel which is hilarious
someone was watching my video on on the
symbolism of flat earth
and there was like a warning underneath
it talk as if
like and then you can tell that youtube
just does it i guess they probably
associate
certain things in my videos and and
because i also made a video on
symbolism of conspiracy theory and so
they probably think that i'm a flat
earther or something which is hilarious
um yeah all right so josh the mover asks
could you discuss the distinction
between whole burnt offerings and
partially burnt sacrifices is there a
contemporary application for this
language
or are they simply anti antiquated
categories that are no longer necessary
because of the incarnation
i think the distinction is important the
distinction is
important to understand and
[Music]
they're it's important to understand in
terms of like
extremes you could say because we have
to understand that the
partially burnt sacrifice was a meal
it was eaten by um
by the people right and so there are
certain types of lives which could be
called
whole burnt offerings holocaust
offerings and uh
for example let's say a um a mystic
or a hermit who lives in his cave and
he lives in secret his whole life could
be called something of
uh like a holocaust offering rather than
a
a regular sacrifice you know because it
doesn't
it doesn't at least visibly end up
looking like it participates in
the physical world but rather it looks
like it's completely given up to god
and the idea is that it does end up
having fruits
in the world but those fruits are let's
say more are less visible at the outset
they're more
widespread and they're more you know and
that type of person
acts more like a pillar of the world and
you can imagine the hobart offering kind
of doing that as well like this column
of smoke going up
into the sky and then once you're done
there's nothing left and so this
this this pillar that acts acts as a
kind of foundation for
reality in its self-sacrifice you could
say
and so i think that i think that uh
certain types of monastics are like that
and i also think that
probably martyrs are also
akin to holborn offerings where
you know their lives are completely
taken up
and they they they're taken from the
world and so they don't
it's not let's say like and it's not
like someone
who helps the poor or is involved in the
community or
you know or someone who is is in a
monastery and ends up teaching others
you know the martyr just especially the
young martyrs
the the martyrs in the early church and
we don't know anything about them and
then they're
that we know what we know about them is
their martyrdom and then they just go up
in this whole birth offering and then
they act as seeds for the
for the church more so than other types
of sacrifices or more
other types of communions with god at
least that's my understanding of it
so samuel says in the lord of spirits
podcast father
damick am i i i never pronounced against
his word
his name right sorry father father
stephen talks about the idea that
satan is jealous of mankind's ability to
become sons of god through theosis
and this is not an angel's fate how
would you
understand that pattern symbolically or
in terms of the way
you have explained fallen angels as
wayward principalities previously
what is the symbolic pattern underlying
this idea and so
and so you could understand the idea
that it is possible
for something above to desire
that which is below and
the desire for body it's not it's not
that hard to understand the desire for
body and so
you can imagine that as as you desire
stuff right as you want to get the new
car you want to get nice clothes or you
want to get a
or in my case i want a house you know
in that desire if you that desire can
scale up and you can understand
principalities that become obsessed with
a
with a a desire for that which is below
and then
lose themselves in that desire and kind
of fall into it and so it's
and so the the normal communion of
angels is a hosting of angels
right and you can understand abraham
hosting the angels that come down and so
there's a proper relationship
and the hosting is akin to
you know it's it's it's analogical to to
sexuality it's not the same but it's
like a different versions of the same
symbolism
it's a more it's a less complete
communion let's say than
than a sexual relationship but
nonetheless it is a type of
receiving from above you know into a
house into your home and then
offering hospitality um
[Music]
and so i think that that and so one of
the things that the
the notion is that the angels see us
as instead of being really really high
up we are more of the union of all
of all possibilities together so we we
have invisible and divisible together
so there is a way in which we are more
than the angels and that's kind of a
mystery
but there is a way in which we're more
than the angels because we are
we can properly unite with the physical
world we don't need
we don't have the intermediaries let's
say between it's like we are between the
world and the angels just like
we can imagine that the angels are kind
of between us
and god you know and so they kind of see
something similar
but we have access because we have the
invisible
then we also have we actually do have
access to the higher spheres so
anyways that's the way i understand it
by the way you need all of you just
check out father stephen
um and father de young's de young's
podcast the the last one on giants was
just
great you know they said some crazy
stuff in there that is like is not gonna
make is not gonna make a lot of
modernists happy but
their description of the nephilim in
that podcast was really wonderful
because
they basically explain they explain
both the the like the physical causality
and they also explain how it links
really links to the
to to this narrative pattern of
and these beings that are real that you
know that these principalities are not
just our projections they
they're real and they have they have uh
will and volition in the world and so
they talk about how
basically the nephilim the the way that
angels and
women made it to create the giants
was through ritual ritual practice and
so
a priest or a king would stand in and
would be possessed by the
the god and then would have a
relationship with uh with a prostitute
or
or a woman and then that the fruit of
that would end up being these
these kind of demonic beings or these
beings that are
possessed by these principalities and so
those were the giants and i thought like
and and and it makes so much sense
because it's something that you see
happening
like if you read even the story of
alexander the great there's a
there's a version of that happening in
this in the way that alexander was born
and if you see it in and that he they
talk about how in different cultures
they
found these these uh for example like
something like oggs bed which is like
this 15 foot
large bed which was in a temple and was
used for this
type of ritual and so and it just makes
so much sense to think about it that way
and that it's in the real you know it's
secondary causes they don't talk
we don't think about the secondary cause
but they explain it and and but it's
nonetheless a real relationship between
between the the two worlds and so it's a
yeah it's really worth it i would say
that that that podcast is really uh is
really a great right now
um if
like if my videos if my videos can act
as a way to help people understand that
podcast
i'll be happy if if that's what it could
do so
um because if there is a danger in their
podcast that like people who are kind of
too science fiction minded will
listen to it and not understand what's
going on but if you kind of have a right
grounding and understand
the this hierarchy of beings that exist
in the world then all of a sudden
like then you get this whole narrative
aspect which is perfect to
kind of dive into and participate in so
yeah all right so enough about
enough about that
so why is the structure of the world
with heaven and earth man in the center
and the great multitude of cosmos
microcosms
not sufficient that is to say why does
god have to exist outside of this system
at all
why take the extra step and acknowledge
anything as transcendent
well the one thing that you have to be
careful that god
it's it's a dangerous thing to say that
god exists outside of this system
because
in a way god exists outside of the
system but in
another way god permeates the entire
system and in another way
the whole system is in god and so it's
it's like it's the infinite it's the
category of the infinite it's not a it's
not
uh god is not a being that is outside of
the cosmos that is just not how it is
and and it's just traditional theists
don't think that it's a very much it's a
very that's like a it's a late medieval
up to today
way of thinking that has developed in
the world to think of god as a
as an arbitrary being which is outside
of the outside of the cosmos
it's more that
the categories of being stack
up and stack up and stack up and then at
some point you reach
the place where being hints
at something beyond it something which
is both
itself and not itself which is both
being and not being at the same time
and and so and that fills all
and is the source of all and all is in
god so
all that language is to show you that
it's not it's not that and so
yeah like why is it not enough to have
you know heaven earth and man in the
center
is because there is even something about
man's central
position between the two opposites which
which gives us a yearning for something
which is beyond opposites
like our very position as the link
between these two things gives puts in
us
a yearning for that which is beyond
duality and our capacity to see
a hint of that in us is enough
to get have an intuition of something
which is beyond duality in a greater
in a greater way and so at least that's
the way i see it
all right so luca askovic asks you and
rationality rules talked about the
difference between identity and behavior
can you elaborate more on that what does
constitute
pre-renaissance identity and how is it
different from modern identity can you
please compare examples
of old identities with modern identities
and so
that's a really interesting it's a
really interesting uh
question and it was really it's really
important because one of the things that
we've seen in the modern world
especially in the last you know few
decades is we've seen
an inversion of identity like a complete
inversion of identity
because
you can say that that that in a
traditional world in a normal world your
identity
is your place in the world it's your
place in reality
and so it it it could be your place
in in all the different dynamic
hierarchies of being
uh and so it's like your uh baker or you
know it could be some
position that you hold it can be
something that you do but it
also has to be like a position that you
hold and so
you can let's say you can bake you can
make cook you can make cookies and you
can do that but you can also be a baker
because you have that position in
society where you are
you are have a role call it a role in
society
and so usually uh identities are roles
that
that we play and so that's why man
woman child uh uh you know
all your jobs you know uh let's say uh
in a traditional world you could always
also have things like
different aristocracies clergy uh the
different roles you play for example in
the medieval
theology you had the three orders you
know those who pray
uh those who fight those who work and
those were your identities like you were
they were what you you're
it's not it's more than just what you do
in in the immediate sense and so
one of the things that that has happened
is not only that we have been
identified with what we do because when
we talk about homosexuality
it's even more than just what you do
it's your desire
we have we are now identified with our
desires
and so we we're in a weird we're in a
weird world upside down world where
in the traditional world there's
something stable which is your place in
the world it has a certain
stability it's not 100 stable but it you
have a certain stability and then you
have all the impermanent
aspects of you and your desires are part
of it so for example like
being a married man or being married
that's something which enters into your
identity
it's a place that you have it's a it's a
it's a it's a formal relationship
between two people
and then you know that it's possible
even as you're married
to have desires for other people it can
happen and so but those desires are
impermanent and
and if you ride them through you're just
going to get over you're just going to
get through them and
you'll continue on with your life you
have to work on focusing
your desires in alignment with your
identity
and so now it's like this weird reverse
thing
where your identity has to be focused
and put in line with your desires
and the thing is that your desires
aren't ever changing
and especially now you'll see it because
before we had
the only the idea of let's say
homosexuality but
but that's going away because it's all
fluid now it's all
about fluidity and and and and uh you
know
gender fluidity and your desires just
just float and can end up on anything
if you let it go that way and people
realize that but then because
our desires have become the focus of
identity
then all of a sudden they realize that
they can't have stable identities
because their desires
are just changing all the time and so
it's it really is a problem like it's a
it's a major problem
to to confuse like i said it's not just
behavior behavior already is a problem
if you confuse just behavior with
identity
but if you confuse desire with identity
that's even wilder
that leads us to destruction all right
so timothy aspeslaw asked hey jonathan
i'm trying to figure out the
relationship between the cardinal
directions in the old testament i see a
strong connection between south and west
both are related to death and
multiplicity
the slavery of joseph down in egypt and
the western waters in jonah
i see a strong connection between north
and east
as they are related to return to the
source of identity the garden in the
east and jacob going to his uncle
lavon laban in the north
am i right to see south being closer to
west symbolically than it is to east
as well as north being closer to east
than it is to west so the a good way to
understand
it in terms of bible symbolism is
to understand
to understand east and west as
being it's opposite from us and so the
it's like the vertical axis
is east and so the you face east
um and then so the the east is
the the main direction you could say and
then wet because the sun
goes up and then west is the the
the the end of the world
and then left and right are more the
extreme and so the north
is let's say the south is the
the that's where the sun goes so the sun
goes into the south
and in the north the sun doesn't go into
the north and so the north
is a type of extreme a high extreme you
could say
especially in the scripture because
going north go is up and then going
south is down
uh in the experience of people in
scripture and so
it's more it has it doesn't north
doesn't indeed have to do with idea of
source
you know because it's the mountain and
so it's this it's related to this idea
of source and you can imagine you can
just imagine the vision of these white
capped mountains at the top
of the world and then going down south
towards
egypt you know down into the desert and
into
into a kind of death but north and south
are kind of like extremes
and and both of them have their
dangerous extremes because
if you read in scripture you'll see that
like the the
the invaders always come from the north
you know they come down
like thunder right and they come down
like this this uh
these lightning bolts from heaven and
and come and attack and so
you see that in the whole image of gog
and uh
and magog you know the idea that i
talked about the caspian gates in the
north
and you see it also just in the idea of
all these
these nomadic tribes that would come
down from the north even
even in even in the time of christianity
the huns
and the khazars and the turks and all of
these tribes that kind of and even the
vikings like
they they so the north isn't necessarily
always good it's more
an extreme of something above you
which which can also come down and
and uh take right so
yeah that's how i see it anyways but
there's probably a lot more matsu's book
is
really worth reading in terms of those
those directions as well
[Music]
so dear john so uh so no mad in socks
no nomad in socks uh asks i am
struggling to understand why you have
said in previous videos that symbolism
shouldn't have to be explained instead
you seem to imply that it
should be felt or lived ignorantly in
faith rather than no
so does that relate to adam and eve in
the garden living ignorant of the
knowledge of the fruit i always
understood that symbolism was meant to
be
destroyed by being known and integrated
just like food
it is how we digest the unknown slowly
to the known
the end goal being that all of the
of the unknown of god will be properly
digested the high will come down to the
low and the kingdom will manifest down
on earth with unity in god um said he
gives me a few
analogies the i think there's something
about what you're saying which is
which is right i think there is
something about what you're saying which
is right and it's also related to the
notion that christ said that all
must be revealed that everything that is
hidden must be shown
um but it's a it is in fact a process of
death
and so because it's a process of death
it just means it's a process of death
and so
a lot of will be lost along the way and
so
i do believe that in the end it'll all
be integrated but i also
i also see in the words of christ this
wise you know the wise saying that
scandal must happen
must happen but woe to those by whom it
happens and so
there's a danger making things explicit
which is
when you make things explicit people
think they
understand it by their ex by the
explicit
knowledge but they they lose the lived
aspect of it you know and uh and so
hopefully
look i i do still think this is has to
happen and i do still think that it
at the point where we are it's the best
bet for people to climb the back to
climb back up the ladder
i would just say that i would just say
that
we need to be careful not to think that
because we
understand these this symbolism mentally
that somehow
we have more than those who have
a lived and experienced you know
intuitive approach or you know uh
incarnation of symbolism that's mostly
what i want to get to
so adam says hi jonathan what's the
symbol of red hair i just watched ponyo
and the magician
antonio herself have red hair
so does the little disney uh little
mermaid and supposedly the prophet
muhammad dyed his beard red
i didn't know that is any of this
related or relevant yeah red hair is
very
important has to do with uh red in
general
left hand wild symbolism um
you know esau is red but then atom is
also red
that there it has to do with earth has
to do with
this kind of
i wouldn't say dissolution but a
loosening you could call it something
like that like a loosening of
of of things and so it could be related
to
creativity but it has also been related
to
uh sadly it has been also related to
kind of
um promiscuity in if you look at kind of
the symbolism of mary madeline magdalene
how she has red hair in the west and is
related to that
um and so it it just has it's a sim it's
a symbolism of loosening you could say
and so that's why so you can imagine
atom is red red earth and then god
gathers it and then blows breath into it
but you could also imagine the
the redness of adam if it manifests
itself
um in edom then
then it it can also be a kind of
fragmentation
and a wildness all right so
c c sireda asks so hi jonathan
i read loris good book thanks for the
recommendation
uh in an unwinding confusing world
characterized by multiplicity arsene
falls in love with a stranger he fails
to properly connect his earthly
relationship to unity
spirit and it ends in catastrophe driven
by the unifi
unifying power of his love for the
stranger arseney
rises to spiritual unity where linear
time becomes cyclical and doing so at
the end of his life
circles back to his great failure and is
able to correct it obviously more
nuanced in the book but am i getting the
gist
of the medieval symbolism i mean i think
that that's a pretty good
it's a pretty it's a it's a pretty nice
uh
summary of what happens you know uh
it's a very complex book it's really
hard
it's something that really makes you
think it really is close to the level of
dostoevsky in terms of the complexity of
the
of the actions that the characters
taking and the complexity of the
of the reasons why he's doing things and
you you
you know the action he's doing so it's i
mean it's definitely worth reading
um so tan moose men ask it's deer season
what is the symbolism of hunting
well the symbolism of hunting has to do
with
it it has to do with masculine symbolism
uh
it has to do with the notion of fixing
something
and you know so you could say it's
something like
hunting is like
it's also like making fixing the
territory
so you you there's something moving and
then you shoot it
you throw a arrow you you throw and
access you throw something straight
something like uh something which is
going to to stop
it from moving and so so
you could even imagine that something
like science is a form of hunting
because it it tries to fix you know it's
it's an it's one of the actions of logos
is the idea of
of fixing and so that's why christ talks
about
also being fishermen you know that to to
to take these moving things in the water
and in the
in the fishing it's more about gathering
together but
you could also imagine that as hunting
uh
is it god talks about how he puts the
leviathan on a hook
right and so this you can imagine this
again this thing going down into the
water
and then it stops the leviathan from
moving it fixes it down
um and so it is one of the actions of
the logos which is to
fix multiplicity or to to stop
multiplicity from moving and it's
neither positive nor negative
you know it could be negative too but it
can but it can definitely be
positive
so benjamin rba with the passing of your
countryman
alex trebek you guys know i'm french
canadian by the way i just want you to
know that that there's a
very big difference between french
canadians and uh
other canadians but that's okay we won't
go into that too much what are your
thoughts on the symbolic
significance of cultural power of the
show jeopardy
is there more a more metaphysical
shortcoming in western's inflation
something important so true yeah
any thoughts on the show's format the
question and answer the name jeopardy
yeah i mean it's like yeah definitely
it's fluff mostly i would say
i would say it's just fluff it's fluff
in the sense that it's
it's a you know it like you said it's
trivia this this uh
this thing this idea that random facts
and all these facts have meaning in
themselves have value
um at least that's how i see it
all right okay so we're done with the
website
and let's move on to subscribe star
all right so nicola asks the question
that i'm not going to answer usually
niko i answer all your questions but
i'm not going to go into this the creed
of the orthodox church states that the
holy spirit proceeds from the father
but the roman catholics have the
filioque edition can you explain
what each of the statements mean and how
did filioque
change the western christianity i will
be
totally honest with you i am i am
very much um in line
with the orthodox creed i am
definitely orthodox but
i don't fully
get this like i just don't i i and
and it's a weakness on my part i've i've
looked
at people trying to explain it
you know um but i struggle to totally
i don't see like i can see how i can see
how it's a problem in terms of the
formulation
but i don't see the connection between
the problem
and the rest so when i read i listen to
some theologians they'll try to explain
how
this changed which happened you know in
the creed in the west
how it then gave birth to all these
changes which brought about
the modern world and all of that i don't
i don't
see it like i i struggle to understand
the connection and maybe it's a weakness
on my part
you know i'm not i'm not really a
theologian
but uh i just struggle to to understand
it so nikola i'm sorry
but i definitely i definitely say the
creed the orthodox creed so
and i'm that's not gonna change but but
i i don't have
enough to explain it to you so adrian
m malian
it seems to me that the crossing over of
the right left hand which you have
referred to previously is bound up with
saint andrew
first he was a father of john the
foreigner and also brother of the
to apostle peter zimbabwe seems to have
both left-handed right-hand associations
his preaching in byzantium and to the
ruse associates him with many orthodox
with many orthodox consider the second
and third incarnation of rome left hand
moving to right also his crucifixion on
the x-shaped cross seems to be symbolic
of his crossing over
from the heavenly right to earthly left
and vice versa do you think
i am on the right track what are your
interpretations of the stories of saint
andrew
the way that i understand andrew
definitely i think saint andrew is
related to the left hand
just because he is always he's always on
the left and icons and he has wild hair
and so he has this wild hair
which maybe comes from the tradition
that he was um you know
a uh follower of john the foreigner
and so but the way i understand saint
andrew is that he's the one who goes to
the edge of the world
and so a lot of his symbolism and a lot
of his stories have to do with going to
the edge of the world and i think that's
even
i was even writing to someone about this
recently about
i think that that's also what the what
the st andrews cross is about
things that andrews cross is about a
cross which goes to the corners
of the earth and and i think that that's
what
saint andrew you know man is manifesting
and so yeah
[Music]
okay so
mr horst says i'm wondering for what
reason christianity usually has more
women in churches than men
usually the ratio i've seen is two to
one in islam in judaism
i have heard that the reverse is true do
you have some idea why this
could be the case um
i mean it's definitely possible that
the mother of god has a role to play in
that
it is definitely possible that the fact
that the church is
itself feminine in the way that it is
described
um it is also possible that it is
related to this
symbolism of the
of the how can i say this
this recognition that the question comes
before and the answer comes after and so
the body
appears and then there's this connection
you know and so the mother of god
says yes and then the incarnation
happens and then you see that
in christianity i talked about this
before in many talks where
after that you can see how there's
always women preceding men
in every let's say mass conversion and
so whether it's constantine and his
mother
whether it's you know prince vladimir
and his grandmother
whether it's there's so many examples
all these kings that convert
always their mother their wife their
sister converts before
whether it's augustine where it's the
cappadocians you know
um it's just uh it's just this it's just
a repetition
of mary magdalene you know seeing the
risen christ
first and then after that and so it has
to do with this relationship between
masculine and feminine um and the way
that it's seen in
christianity i think
all right and so so mr kelly alvin
madden asks
what meaning do twins have esau and
jacob were twins saint thomas was a twin
saint luke mentioned that saint paul's
missionary team sailed in a ship
that had the twin gods greek
god caster in politics as a figurehead
some cultures kill one of the babies
when twins are born yes
and so twins twins have to do
with the problem of two things which
have the same
let's say this the same body or are
of the same or come out at the same time
it's of the same womb at the same time
in the sense that and that's one of the
reasons
why there's this image of the good twin
and the bad twin this is just an
inevitable structure
that's going to show up because if you
have two things
that are um let's say
that that are uh balanced next to each
other then
there's going to be an inevitable
tendency to say good
bad or you know black white or
we we we tend to
have opposites when we have a symmetry
and so
this is just an inevitable aspect and so
this is what happens
in the idea of the twins is that
you have a symmetry but the symmetry
appears as two opposites
so it's not it's not symmetry in the
sense that the two are the same it's
symmetry in the sense that you have
say you can imagine that both twins
together are a total being
and because they're like two halves of
one being
then they will appear with this in this
opposite
and so that is probably why many
cultures will
either kill or see one of the twins
as cursed or evil or whatever just
because of this problem
this problem of of uh
of how we are built to to to see
but you know and it's like you know it's
funny because you see it if you want to
understand
for example in the united states you
have two parties
and just because you have two parties is
just because you have two parties then
it will inevitably split right down the
middle
and you'll always have like you know all
near 50
of people going one side and near 50 of
people going the other side
and then they will they will line up on
opposite sides of every single possible
um you know question that you can ask
and so they'll line up
against each other and it's just going
to happen it's just inevitable
when you have twos of something and so
uh you know and it's it's there's an
opportunity in the sense that there's a
dynamism in that
but there's also a real danger because
you know you you end up with these two
opposites that are
that are just facing each other and uh
and so that's the symbolism of
twins
all right and so now let's go to
patreon which has like 34 questions i
think
it's like it's quarter to 10. am i gonna
be able to do this
we'll see let's see all right
all right so i have and now it's oh it's
35 i shouldn't have reloaded the page is
what i
shouldn't have done okay
here we go and so let's see let's just
do this let's just go all out
you know hopefully people at least it
says jonathan's panic laugh
and so you can recognize the differences
between my different my different laughs
huh um
all right
um and so so brad says that
that uh
yet you need to have a healthy
masculinity and that's why the church
fell in the west and men don't attend
there is for sure a there is for sure a
pattern
in orthodoxy which is the which is kind
of the opposite that i've seen in other
cultures which is
that it's usually the men that want to
go and then it's often
the women who don't or you'll find the
you'll find the opposite of men who go
to church and women who don't
that i've seen i've seen quite a bit in
orthodoxy
compared to other other traditions
all right so so kevin patterson
asks i attended a professional
development program called landmark they
train you to let go of bad things that
happened to you
in your past by seeing it
it was all your interpretation of the
event which causes your suffering
example my father hit me and i attached
meaning to it an evil
then they tell you all meaning is just
an illusion and that everything is
interpretation
and all your judgments are just your
machinery program
talking is this the antichrist message
um look
i would say that there's an aspect of
this which is obviously
problematic right to say that
that you can manipulate reality let's
say
that you can manipulate um
facts in order to make reality what you
want it to be is definitely a problem
that is definitely not
not um not true
but there's something about let's say
something
a glimmer in what you're saying which is
related to something which is real which
is that
you could call it more like attachment
to something and so
our attention on something and so for
example
if you hold on to things like if you
if someone hurt you or someone insulted
you
and you hold on to that then it will
make you suffer that's for sure uh but
if you
if you forgive and if you let go then
that thing will cease to have power over
you
so it's not so much about about changing
the what happened or or you know um
but it's really about uh forgiveness and
not
letting events and people have power
over you
through what they did to you and so in
that sense i think that it's true if
that's what they're doing
um
so g garcia asks hello jonathan you
don't typically talk about economics but
i was wondering what you thought about
currency
could we view replacing a gold standard
for fiat currency and attempting to
control inflation
as tower of babelesque i would say
definitely
in terms of tower of babel
you know it and so it's interesting
because you can see that
one of the things that
one of the things that the the current
monetary system because it's kind of
detached itself from
from hard goods or from things that are
solid
then what it has done is it has opened
up way more possibility and so it's
actually
it's actually opened up all this
possibility but then it's also
made value extremely fragile
and so it's made value extremely fragile
and based on
on the whims of people and so you can
imagine that in a
let's say in a more traditional normal
world you know you needed goods and so
you
you know you had a stone building you
had goats you had cows you had
stuff and no matter what would happen in
the world there would always be a
certain value
in those things because those things are
there and they exist in the world and
they have
they have value they have a reality they
have a
reason why they're valuable and so as we
as we kind of abstracted that into this
the system
of value that is not completely linked
then it like i said it what it's done is
it's actually created a lot of
of option and opportunity especially
with credit um but
it's it's fragile and so it can crack
and everybody knows because
you know you had moments in we always
forget it's not that far ago let's say
in the 1930s uh
crisis where the system collapsed and
it's not like there weren't wasn't any
food there was food there
were objects but because the currency
collapsed and because the whole
economic system collapsed on one side of
the country people were dumping out food
and into into the ground and on the
other side
people were starving and so that's the
fragility of the
of the of the monetary system and so it
could that could definitely happen
again hopefully not but um yeah
so charlie longoria says your video with
rationality rules is great
watch it a few times is there anything
you wish you could have communicated
better wish you had said
at the time thank you for everything you
do for sure i think that i definitely
failed in the way that i communicated
with him
obviously and you can see that i failed
because i feel like
i feel like he missed the points that i
was trying to
make or that he was getting them
partially not totally
that's at least that that's the
impression i get and i also noticed if i
and so on his channel i tried to read a
lot of the comments
and i think a lot of the comments came
off as if i was just trying to
justify what i think justify my
christianity through argumentation which
i don't know like i think that if you
guys have watched my channel for
for the last few years it's like i don't
feel like that's what i'm doing
um um but you know and so we'll see
so steven has said he he was kind of
disappointed also in the way
that people are reacting to the video
kind of like i am and the same i think
with my
i think that he really really made it
real genuine effort
and i could see that he was making the
effort you know
and so i appreciated that and i saw that
in my channel a lot of people were just
kind of going after him saying he didn't
understand and everything
and so yeah he said that he would be
willing to do another discussion so
maybe we will but
i would have to feel like it's going to
be fruitful so he said he's going to
make a video
to summarize his ideas about
about our discussion and then maybe i'll
do something similar
which i'll try to be more concise and
take into account
the places where i saw that i was not
communicating properly or that i wasn't
getting across and then maybe try to
summarize that
also and then we'll see if that that
seems fruitful then maybe we can have
another
another discussion but i mean i i can't
say for 100 that it would be worth it
so so keenan wang asks i think about the
symbolism of too much right-handedness
as fire
and brimstone too much left-handedness
as flooding
is there a symbolism for how they come
together
um and so yeah it's complicated with the
left and the right hand
it's complicated because man it's okay
you know we talked about i've talked
about this
several times the problem of the cross
like how they cross over
um but that's fine if you want to say
see it that way
you know don't forget that it's the
people on the left hand that go
into the fire right and there's people
on the right hand that go come into the
kingdom
but you could you can understand that
it's the right which is casting out
and it's the left which is bringing in
it just depends on how you see it but
let's say that uh the symbolism of from
how they come together
is definitely something that you'll see
in
in scripture right and so you can
understand the symbolism of how they
come together
in something like the
the like israel right so and so in the
old testament
israel is the place where these two
extremes come together and so
the way you see it the the stories in
which you see that is
when the israelites leave egypt
in order to receive the law of god so
they're actually moving out of
death and they're coming together in
order to now receive like adam is being
gathered together
in order to receive the law from heaven
right and so this is what's happening
when israel is leaving egypt they're
being gathered out from
from the ground from the south talked
about that before
and they're going to receive the law and
as they're doing that
they are held together
between two pillars and there's the
pillar of fire and there's the pillar of
smoke but it's more like a pillar of uh
of a
mist or like a cloud pillar and so
there's water and fire
and that is kind of and there in between
this water
and fire these two these two pillars are
like the two extremes
which are uh guiding them in their
opposite right
and so so there's an image of that and
then
if you want to bring it down closer to
something smaller you could say that
so the people of israel being gathered
together and then the temple
in scripture is also that plague because
don't forget that there are two pillars
in the temple
and those two pillars are the equivalent
of the fire pillar and the water pillar
they're two they're equivalent of the
two the two sides let's say the two
extremes um and so
so yeah so that's that's how i would say
and so you can imagine like in scripture
you could imagine that
the fire comes from heaven this is
something which is which is always
hard harder because
lightning comes from comes down from
heaven okay and then the water
is there well water comes from heaven
too sometimes but
you can imagine the the the middle as
being something like dry land
you know that inhabitable land if you've
read my metoo's book you'll understand
that as well
as that which is between the two
extremes
anyways hopefully those analogies were
enough for you to understand
it didn't sound like i was just saying
anything
so benjamin kincaid says hey jonathan
could explain why we refer to god the
father
as the father uh also i've heard that
the holy spirit can be
thought of as the feminine piece of the
trinity is that a correct way of
thinking about it
uh and so i mean god the god is
the father because he's the origin of
the world like he's the origin in the
sense of
he's he's that out of which comes the
logos
you could say that way and so the sun
the sun comes from the the father
uh and so manifestation comes down so
the father
if you you understand it as ultimately
this idea of
the all the naming all the speaking
all the identities come down from the
father and
if you actually read some of the church
fathers for example like saint ephraim
the syrian
he sees in terms of feminine he actually
sees
rather the divine essence as as
he talks about the divine womb and so
he has he has this image of this kind of
unspeakable
or un unsaid uh
essence which is something like the
divine womb out of which
god in which god exists as a trinity
um and so that's rather the imagery that
i've seen
in some of the fathers that i like in
terms of how
let's say the feminine functions and so
but
the creation itself is also seen as the
feminine
counterpart of the of the father um
anyways that's mostly how i
see it especially if you understand
theosis if you understand that the real
the reason for creation is theosis then
you can understand how
creation has a feminine aspect which is
which is meant ultimately to be fully
united with god
and fully participating in god's
existence
so yeah those are the two
so vic serda asks although angelic
beings are ultimately genderless
androgynous
when they appear to the prophets and the
saints they appear as young men
probably due to them following the
patterns of heaven
and the logos which is masculine but
since all the foreign gods of the
nations are fallen principalities what
about
the foreign goddesses like ishtar diana
ashura et cetera
what patterns of the spirits who
manifest themselves as feminine
follow
that's an interesting question i hadn't
really thought about that
very much
i would have to think about that
they they would the way to understand it
would probably to understand
how it within
within the world of of principalities
you could probably understand that there
are something like feminine
and masculine aspects of of all the
different
all the different uh aspects of reality
which are being manifested in these
different
these different gods and so that's
probably has probably has something to
do with that
because it it's it's too simplified like
a lot of people have this theory about
mother earth
which is which is too simplified in
terms of understanding
how the feminine appears in the world of
uh
kind of gods and goddesses but
yeah let's think about it more one
thing's for sure is that it seems like
like mary like the mother of god has
taken up
all the titles all the titles of these
different goddesses she's kind of taking
them
uh as as you know and and kind of think
let's say manifested them in their
proper place in relation in relation to
the infinite and not
in a confused way all right
so jail asks good morning evening
jonathan
it's a long question um i'm gonna have
to skip your question there
uh jail all right so a question in your
carbon practice
how do you yourself find the right
balance of abstraction
all right so it's related to this
problem of abstraction in the modern
world
let me read the comment okay so i've
been thinking a lot about extraction and
its effect on the modern world
we can turn on a light switch and expect
the lights to come on
without knowing what goes into work into
its working we use words in a way that
we know
that we know not their metaphorical
origins and if at all only know how they
describe the physical world perhaps
okay so i feel like it's corruption
disenchants the world
and can remove us from the present a way
out of this perhaps could be learning
how the lights come on or practicing
gratitude before flipping switch or
learning the etymology of the word we
use
a question how in your carving practice
how do yourself find the right balance
of abstraction
obviously forging the steel for your
tools is too
little abstraction mining that steal too
little yet using the power
tools maybe too much sure you'd stop at
programming a robot to turn out an icon
to say christopher
yeah that's definitely there's
definitely a question that in terms of
it's like i don't know if i would i
would i don't know if i would use the
word attraction
but i think i understand what you're
saying um you could say something yeah
something
in the sense of being removed you know
and it is the problem of
using tools um
and so i think that i think that
tools you have to understand tools that
cover as an extension of your being
and there is a process by which the
further away you get from your being
like
more levels you add the more there's a
danger
of the tool taking over what you're
doing
right and that is just something which
seems inevitable
you know there's a great example of how
miyazaki
was making animated drawings with uh
with animations using drawing so he was
drawing all the characters and
you know and it was a very long and
laborious process so he got
uh he was able to integrate computer
generated
uh animation which he would then maybe
animate over but he would use the basic
the basic thing under underlying the
animation would be computer animated
[Music]
and then miyazaki noticed that the
animators were now adjusting their
designs and their
their storytelling to what the computer
could do
rather than using the computer as a tool
to express what they were trying to
express
and when he discovered that of his
animators he threw out
all the the computers and said back to
the drawing board like let's go back to
drawing
and so i think that there's something
about that
uh and so for example like if i'm
working on an icon
the way that i've set it up is that i
kind of have a hierarchy of practice
which means that there are some work in
the icon which is
more like a rote
work and so when
i'm making taking the background out for
example i'm not at all afraid to use
a router like a you know a mechanical
router
and you know if i'm cutting the the
boards i'm not afraid to use mechanical
tools if i'm joining
the boards i'm not afraid to use
mechanical tools none of that bothers me
but for sure the more i get into
the figure the more i get into the
meaning of the piece then the closer
i will get to my hand until you know if
i'm making the eyes then i
have a knife and i'm holding the knife
you know right at the tip
and i'm just kind of really it's like my
finger goes right up against the
carving and so i think that that's maybe
the best way to understand it is that
you know that the
closer you get to the the parts of your
life that are meaningful
the more you want to be connected and
then for
the things that are less important or
less meaningful then you don't have to
worry so much about
about that problem of being removed from
it you know
because you know
it's just it's just inevitable like you
you
most people in their households in the
ancient times would have had servants
would have had people
who work for them who would have done
other chore that they weren't
necessarily
kind of uh aware of it's totally
connected to
so that's the way i see it anyways hope
that answers because it
is a hard question so uh paul jamal
asks hi jonathan can you give us a brief
overview of the symbolism of vaccines
thank you for your work and so so the
symbols of symbolism of vaccines is the
double symbolism of the garments of skin
so on the one hand it is it can be
death taking on some aspect of death in
order to
preserve yourself from death so to take
in of aspect of the disease in order to
heal from the disease
to to uh yeah to take some of the poison
in order to
be immune to the to the poison um
but that's not it's not a it's not a
one-way street because
because taking in death is taking in
death
right so if you if you if you give
and the that's why the garments of skin
are a dangerous
a dangerous road they're on the one hand
they're inevitable
but on the other hand they're dangerous
and this is related maybe to the to the
technology symbolism that we talked
about is that
the more you add on the more you
give in to this process of death turning
against death
the more you are getting the closer you
are also getting to death
and so like and so i think that in terms
of the vaccines i think that
you right now is a time to be very
attentive
and and not be weird about it
just be attentive to what is asked of
you
in terms of the vaccine because the
vaccine
will come with other requirements there
will be other things that it's not just
a vaccine
there are other things involved and you
have to just be attentive to all that is
asked of us and all that is
all that it encompasses in terms of
not just some taking some vaccine or not
you know there's nothing wrong i don't
think there's anything wrong with a
vaccine in itself
but it is a it is like i said it's a
giving in to death and so
we have to we just have to be attentive
not to compromise ourselves
so that's as close as i can get because
you know it's like
we'll see you know a lot of people are
scared right now because of
you know kogan and all that stuff and i
think they have a reason to be
um but it doesn't necessarily mean that
we just have to be attentive and not
give in to hysteria
but also not be naive about what's going
on and and yeah
and make our decisions once it is time
to
to make that decision and be ready for
the consequences of your decision
um all right
so eb
in the psalms the psalmist talks a lot
about god delivering israel from the
heathen nations
as modern christians when we pray with
the psalms that use this idea
we think of demonic principalities today
uh
yeah that's definitely part of it
another part of understanding
uh this imagery in the psalms and how it
can relate to you
it has to do with your passions so if
you read
it like in saint germain you get that
imagery all the time where
the the foreigner is your passions
right because it's this strange thing
which is both seductive and destructive
at the same time
which is on the edge of you and so all
the imagery that you see
like in you know for example like when
it says that
uh moses killed the egyptian also saint
gregory
will say see it as you know
say that that moses is put to death his
own passions and the
exterior aspects of himself and so i
think that that's probably the best way
it's probably even better than to think
of it as demonic
principalities because your passions you
know
are closer to you than than demons
even though there can be demons behind
your passions you'll
usually experiment it you won't have the
experiment of it
most of us won't have the experiment of
an actual demon you'll just have the
experiment of an uncro
uncontrollable desire to do something
right or an
uncontrollable personality trait which
will
take over your your your whole
personality more than
you know seeing some dark creature in
the corner of the room or
or seeing some shadow or whatever like
you read you read
the stories of the of the saints of the
especially the ascetics and
you know their life is so full of prayer
and self-awareness
that they experiment these things in an
even more immediate way like they
seem to actually have a sense of these
things
almost almost in a
in a relational way you know with most
of us i don't think have that
i mean if you do actually it's probably
not if you do maybe i feel sorry for you
actually
unless you're uh unless you're an
anaesthetic
so what is that all the what is this
zeros in the chat
this is this is this is neil's doing
what are you doing neil
all right okay so leo asked the ian
mcgill chris
in the master and his emissary notes
that the right brain is critical for
the expression of virtually every
emotion the only exception
is anger that's activated by the left
brain it's
additional symbolism in traditional
symbolism
is anger considered to be fundamentally
different to the other
emotions
that depends like that really depends it
is possible
that it depends how you understand anger
like
if you understand anger as uh
as an idea of offense against you
right that you're reacting to offense
against you
then it could definitely be in line with
the notion of what i call
or what say maximus calls the right hand
sins
uh remember that the brain symbolism
seems to be
reverted from hand symbolism and so the
idea that it has to do with
the the the sin of self-sufficiency
right
um and so it's funny because i'm
actually reading masquerade as emissary
right now
um it's like i'm not super far into it
i'm still at the first chapters but
but uh hopefully i'll have more to say
about it once i'm further in
all right so airy fisher says hi
jonathan i'm painting my very first icon
for my grandfather at the moment using
the mendelian image made image made
without hands template
what is the symbolism of this icon and
the legend behind its origin
of christ sending an image of his face
on a cloth to a distant king to heal him
does it have to do with christ using a
garment to move into the margins
also i remember you saying that you
would give a critique if people sent you
their icons do you still do that
or was it just for card ones or paint
ones too it's mostly for carved ones but
if you send me
if you send me an uh an image of your
icon you know i'll i'll
i'll critique it but just be sure you're
ready because i won't i won't be nice to
you i'll i will critique your
icon uh some people recently have been
very offended at
at the fact that i that i that i've been
critical of their work so
just be careful if you send me stuff um
and so the idea of the mendelian and the
importance of the mendelian has mostly
to do
with the reality of the image and it
has mostly to do with the reality of the
image
as as in the notion of prototype
in the notion of how the image has a
has a spiritual reality to it and so
so you can understand that it's not the
piece of cloth it's the image and so
christ it is like it's like a reversal
of the second commandment or like an
accomplishment of the second commandment
which is that christ god has given us
back the image in christ because
you have to remember that we are created
in god's image
and christ gives us back the image
through the incarnation and so christ
puts his image on the cloth
and then the image goes and then the the
the person is healed
by the image and that if you look at
icons if you look at uh like crosses for
example
russian crosses for example often the
mendelian image
will actually be placed above the
above the icon so you can have the i
cross for example
with christ on it and then at the very
top of the cross you'll have the
mendelian kind of floating there at the
top
and what what it's talking about is that
talking about how
what you see in the icon is pointing you
towards the prototype
it's point pointing you towards the
heavenly image
the image that christ the the
the image of god that god gave us in
christ
which is not just christ in terms of his
bodily existence which it is but it
it it is ultimately some there's
something
there's some aspect of it which is
transcendent and that the image of god
and man
has been has been restored through
christ
hopefully that answers that i hope that
was that was
so sander quitert quitter sorry i'm not
pronouncing that right
so what did you recently come to terms
with man
that's tough um
i don't know if i can be explicit about
that but i think that i think that
i can a thing that i've come to terms
with
recently is has to do because i'm
getting older like i'm in my
40s now i guess like 45 man it's crazy
so i'm like 45
and so i think that i there's i've come
to terms with
the fact that
there are some aspects of my life which
have formed
and there's something about when you're
younger that you
that you're in that you're in a
gestation period it's like
it feels like everything in front of you
is possible right because
you you know the the future is open and
you're
everything is malleable you're learning
you're doing all this and so i've
i've recently come to realize that where
i am
now i've i've kind of shifted into
another stage where
in front of me are not all these
possibilities and that there are some
things which i'm never going to have
uh and that are over that's something
that are finished
in terms of possibility and then there
are some things
which i've been given as precious tools
and precious
uh gifts and that i need to to foster
and to kind of grow uh but it
it it came it's kind of like it's it's
my version of the uh
of like the mid midlife crisis you know
like some things
are finished and some things i don't i i
shouldn't
still hope for because it's just it's
also not worth my time and energy
and then some things i have i need to
consolidate
and and build upon that's what i've
recently come to terms with sorry i'm
not more explicit but it's kind of
personal
um so jason
gaddel gadowaltz asked hi jonathan peace
please for free not to answer this
question what is the symbolism of
hate um
i mean i mean the symbolism of hate is
you can understand it as it depends it
is that word man it's just because of
today
you could understand it as being
noticing that something is not what it
should be
and feeling an extreme passion towards
the fact that things aren't the way they
should and so
it's it's more i sang it more like anger
and so
you can i thought there there is this
idea for example that there are certain
things which are good to hate like hate
your passions
to learn to hate your passions to learn
to feel
anger towards your own sins
you know um and that is definitely in
terms of christianity
that is the way that it's supposed to be
turned like it's supposed to be
turned towards your own failings and
your own passions and your own sins
but obviously we tend to externalize it
and uh and hate others
so elise spinola asked hi jonathan
what's the meaning of christ entering
jerusalem on a donkey
uh that is has pretty much
to do with christ with christ
mastering the the the foreigner
and so this is a really interesting
thing it's like
this is the most one of the most
interesting aspects of christ's
symbolism is that when the messiah
when christ enters jerusalem sitting on
a donkey sitting on an impure animal
and even the even the rabbis and the
early christian fathers
they understood that text which talks
about that the messiah will come
sitting on the the on the back of a
of an ass uh that it had to do with the
messiah
let's say dominating or mastering
the impure mastering the form right uh
and you could see it as a form of
conquering um but in terms of
christianity
it's the supreme let's say the supreme
joke of of uh of christianity that it
did do that but it didn't do it in the
way that people expected
you know and so christ entered on a
donkey
and he ended up also you know
riding rome but it it didn't happen the
way people expected he didn't take over
with a sword
right and so he kind of he went in and
took over from within and then
you know 300 years later the emperor was
converting and
you know the what the jews expected
christ to do
to take over to to vanquish their enemy
to vanquish the
the the romans christ did it he just did
it in a different way
and so that's what the christ sitting on
a donkey is related to
so christopher says when does humility
turn into self-loathing i've always
looked at humility as a chief virtue
[Music]
as pride is a chief sin sometimes i find
it hard to draw the line between the two
even the church fathers talk about
despise the flesh
what do phrases like this mean in that
context thank you
and god bless and so this is this is
going to be tough for you guys to
understand
that we are we are in a way supposed to
to to have a form of self-loathing the
problem with
the way that people see self-loathing
today
not loathing but like self-diminishing
we're not we're supposed
the saints see themselves as nothing and
in that they become the greatest
the problem with the way that we
understand it today you know this idea
of
low self-esteem it's like the low
self-esteem stuff is actually a form of
pride it's not a form of humility
it's like people who have low
self-esteem and are depressed because
they have low self-esteem
are depressed because they think they
deserve better they're depressed because
they they think that they that they
should be better than what they are
and so because they have this this idea
that they should have more that they
should be better that they should do
this then that's why they have low
self-esteem
but if you just think you're nothing
then you're not gonna
you're not going to have that problem
i'm not saying that look this is what i
see in the text
please do not see me this way because i
definitely do not have much humility as
you've noticed
um but uh that's what i see it's like
you know there's a there's interesting
there's actually
this is it's not even a christian uh
example that comes to mind is one time i
heard
someone ask the dalai lama about someone
who was shy
you know and the dalai lama said that
shy people are too
self-important and that's what makes
them shy
people who are shy are self-centered and
and and are thinking about themselves
too much
and i think it's the same with people
who are
who say they hate themselves in the way
that the modern
person hates themselves and then you
know you know
is become self-destructive in in uh
in a bad sense it's because they they
don't really hate themselves
they are unhappy with the way others
treat them and they're unhappy with the
way
that their life is going and they think
that it should go better and they think
that they should do
that they should have more but they
don't and so
it makes you feel like yeah sorry guys
that's tough man i know that what i said
what i'm saying is tough but
that's definitely what i see in in the
father's and it's the difference between
real humility and kind of low
self-esteem
all right okay so
so svetlana sitlana asked
would you please explain the pattern in
the hierarchy of intercessor
intercessory prayer
within marriage monastics and the world
communion of saints angels etc does the
incarnation reinforce
or interrupt the need for intercessory
prayer no i don't think it
it definitely doesn't interrupt the need
different
intercessory prayer it it it
grows it by like hundreds of
hundred times like how much intercessory
prayer do you see in the old testament
you don't see a lot of intercessory
prayer you'll see the prophets pray
for others you'll see the priests pray
for others
uh and then you'll see people you know
uh
ask for forgiveness for their sins and
do all that but the idea that we're all
praying for each other constantly they
were supposed to they were
constantly supposed to be praying uh for
everybody
and that and that we're all kind of
praying for each other this network
of logos where we are all we are
all looking out for the best of others
and they're
all looking out for our best and we are
all you know praying for our authorities
and our authorities are praying for
those that follow them and
this kind of circle of prayer in this
circle of logos
is really one of the most amazing
aspects of christianity
is this this like it's a network of
speaking and of
asking and of uh you know and so this
this idea that we attend to the needs of
others that we attend to
to in our relationship with god is
really an image of the church itself
like it's a
it's an em it's an image of you know and
how we
ask the saints to pray for us and we ask
others to pray for us and so
we pray for others they pray for us
and then we ask them to pray for us and
then we ask
those who are already glorified to also
pray for us and so
there's this like massive like circle of
of constant
prayer which is constant logos constant
interaction of meaning
in a community and so it binds us
together you know
and i say that and i'm horrible at him
intercessory prayer like i
i i
i struggle to make it like a really
important part of my
of my of my life like when someone asked
me to pray for them
usually like i think about it for a
little while and then i used it like i
see people
these amazing people like prayer
warriors who have you know like lists of
people and that people that have asked
them to pray for them and then they
in their daily prayers they'll like name
off the names of the
of the different people and have
thoughts for all these people that have
asked them to pray for them man like i
wish i had that discipline
and that uh fervor
okay so
jason lindsay says hey jonathan i'm
curious if the eastern orthodox have the
same stance as catholics on creation
coming ex-nilo
a lot of your talks have been about the
creation of the world there seems to be
an implication that something other than
god does exist
even if it's just some vague undefined
counter potential that god organizes
into being
is this perhaps instead an issue with
how modern people interpret the concept
of nothingness
with the water describing genetics to be
classified as nothing else by ancient
people while
a modern person see it as material
phenomena thank you for
any insight into this so the idea to
understand that god
the importance of creation ex nilo is
that that there is
nothing opposite god that god is beyond
all categories god is beyond all
definition
all name all distinctions
and so god creates
x2 extremes in and so usually i don't
talk about that first part because that
first part
what is there there to say about that
first part it's like god creates
heaven and earth right and so usually
when i'm talking about creation
i'm always talking about what comes
after that
it's like that even in in in scripture
it almost feels like when
the way that it when it says god created
heaven and earth it's almost like it's
not even part of the day
sometimes it feels like it's not even
part of the day it's like before even
the days it's it's just this thing just
this thing which happens beyond all
categories
and so god creates these two categories
heaven and earth and these two
categories
are also not like really part of
creation like
in terms of physical terms they're
they're these two extremes of being
these two extremes of of of existence
you know there's
there's the extreme of potentiality and
an extreme of name essence or whatever
you want to
classify it and it's only really like on
the third day that anything
that they're talking about is actually
talking about anything that has to do
with what we
encounter like that we any category that
we actually encounter like
you never encounter pure
heaven or you never encounter pure
unformedness and that's not
nothing it's it's already it's already
lower it
it's already not what what what is
talking about when it says that we talk
about how god created out of nothing
when we say god created out of nothing
we're pretty much saying that
he created it out of himself like he is
he
is not and i don't want you to get like
a pantheistic vibe from what i'm saying
but it's mostly to say that
it's an outpouring of god but it's not
it's he is
all in all in the end like god is all
creation is in god and god fills all
creation
and although there isn't there's an
absolute separation between the infinite
and the
the finite or manifest world there is
also a
complete inevitable complete uh
let's say permeating of god in the world
it just can't
avoid that so sorry hopefully you guys
aren't reading this is pantheism that's
not what i mean but it's
yeah it's mostly when we say ex nilo
it's mostly that
because you see in earth in other
mythological
uh groups more other mythological
stories where
there's this sense that the world starts
with duality it starts with these two
beings in conflict or these two beings
that are lovers
you know uh and and god and in the
creation
that we find in in traditional
hebrew scripture or in christianity and
in other traditions have
this same thing is that that
the infinite is beyond the first duality
it's it's not uh
yeah all right so hopefully that answers
that
all right so nick scott asks hello mr
president is there anything symbolic
about the moon and its phases with
regards to how it might affect the human
body
i assume there are many places of
symbols surrounding the harvest but the
rest of it always seemed a bit new aging
to me
thanks in advance i mean
if you want the the moon if you
understand the moon it's mostly almost
have to understand the moon as
how it is a it's a it's a
waning waxing that's the moon it's
understand the moon as
moving from darkness to light and from
light to darkness
and so in that sense it's more it's more
related to kind of immediate
patterns and so you know and it's
related also to
the the cycle of fertility
in the sense of the women's the woman's
monthly cycle as well which is related
to this this
becoming full and being and being able
to receive
light with being able to receive seed
and then
becoming dark and then you know
not being able to receive seed and so it
has to do with that
hopefully that makes sense so drew
mcmahon asks
you talk about how jesus feels the
hierarchy that he is the first and the
last
encompasses the top and bottom and is
both cain and abel does this
idea follow all the way down to satan
is jesus also somehow is jesus somehow
also satan
it sounds like a blasphemous question so
forgive me if it is out of line but i'm
trying to see how far and deep
the idea goes and trying to understand
how satan
can fit in a world of an all-good
all-knowing all-powerful god
so it's important to understand that
when i say that
christ fills the hierarchy
and that when i say he is both cain and
abel
i'm not saying that christ is the person
of cain and the person of abel i think
it's really let's be careful about that
uh i'm mostly saying that
he is healing or saving the
the the aspects of
of cain and abel like the problem of
cain and abel got
christ is manifesting the solution to
that problem you know by
offering the the the sacrifice of
of bread and offering his flesh right
and so
there are other aspects of christ which
are which are uniting cain and abel
together
um and i think that in terms of satan
you know it's like
yeah i mean i think that for sure i
would have to say
that the best way to understand that
is mostly to understand how christ
you could say christ replaces satan is a
better way to understand that
it's not it to understand that christ
replaces satan in the sense that
christ replaces
the the as he fills up the hierarchy
then this place of the first angel or
the highest angel
or you know the angel of the of uh
that is the the highest in the hierarchy
which is filled with pride
christ flips that and he becomes the
first
in the hierarchy through humility
and so he actually takes the place
that satan has he feels that with
himself
uh you know while remaining god at the
same time i'm not saying that he
that he is losing himself in this this
this going down and so
that's probably the best way to
understand how christ
you know let's say
inverts the the fall of satan that
that through humility he takes the first
place
where whereas satan through pride lost
the first place
hopefully that helps to understand that
a little bit
um is there a symbolic significance
to the two different notion on judas's
judas his death you mean on the two ways
that it's described that he died
um yeah it's true i like
i've actually thought about that but i
don't think i've totally found
uh a solution because
they look like they're kind of these two
extremes right the the two
that there's one what is it that it's
like he hangs from a tree
and then the other one is that he
he dies what i forget that's horrible
that i'm not
it what's the other thing it's something
about how he like he his
innards like exploded or something
that he bashed his bash on a rock
so he falls headlong and he hits his
head on the rock and he
and he and he dies and so
yeah so you can i think that that has to
do with the two extremes
so it's like he hangs straight down from
a tree
or then he falls down and hits his head
on a rock and so it seems like it has to
do with that like a vertical and a
horizontal extreme
um but i haven't thought about it enough
probably because it's probably really
important actually
i should probably think about it more
before i answer that
all right
um
all right so jesse blaney asked as the
drama of kobe continues
are we fated to relive out the story of
daniel and the lions
and the deeper question here
if is if biblical stories are archetypal
enough to manifest physically
so i'm not sure i understand what you
mean
by daniel in the lines you mean the idea
of not
being asked to worship something and
then refusing
uh i mean sure i don't know if it if it
had to do with coping but that's
obviously something which can always
happen
you know and you know communism was an
example of that exactly where
people were asked to worship something
and
and then if they refuse or if they
continue
to place god as their highest
focus you know in in they continue to
play god as their highest focus
then it was trouble for them and they
would end up in the gulag
um maybe not everybody but
at least those that were at least those
who were that would publicly refuse to
bow down
like daniel did you know
all right
so amy asked hi jonathan i would like to
elaborate more on the culture of
war regarding big tech you brushed on it
in recent interviews with rodriguez
where you both spoke of the danger of
data
data collection and the soft
totalitarian state that's been created
because of it i increasingly feel as
though the culture war
is heightened on these platforms and is
used as a tool of conditioning and
control to promote
engagement through outrage yeah ensuring
big tech can make as much money as
possible
mining and selling our data while we
focus on each other
are you able to shed light on
understanding the structure of
manufactured chaos and control thanks
i think that this is really an example
of you know when i told you that i've
mentioned this three times it's like
when i tell you that ai is probably the
best way you can understand a fallen
angel
i think that there's something of that
going on
like i really think when you listen to
uh jack and uh
what's his name facebook guy zuckerberg
you really feel like they that they lost
control of their monster
it's like they had these intentions of
making these
these these uh these creatures and you
know and you can imagine them as the mad
scientists all excited and then they
pull the switch and they're like it's
alive and they're all excited
and then all of a sudden all the side
effects of their
project starts to manifest itself and
now they are
stuck and so
i don't think that they planned for
outrage to become
the center of social media but i think
it's because they don't know
what human beings are that they fail to
see that
and that they don't have the wisdom
needed to do what they did
which is why it happened and so now that
it's happening
uh for sure there's definitely
people that are going to politically
maneuver that to their advantage
um and i think that that's
the of course it is the danger the this
whole tech thing is dangerous because
although for now the companies mostly
want just to sell us stuff but we can
see how the companies are being
politicized and so as the companies are
becoming politicized then
the data the data mining is going to
become more and more politically tinted
it's just inevitable
there's no conspiracy about it it's just
happening already and so
you know yeah i don't know it's like at
some point
what's going to happen i mean maybe
we'll have to leave
the so the the platforms it's possible
that can happen
so so
norm khan says hi jonathan
might an idea of the christian might
might a function of the idea of the
christian eschaton be
as a means of hope or guidepost to pull
you out of the lowest of lows
when your story no longer affords you
meaning and you find yourself in between
stories
any other insight you may be able to
offer into this mystery would be great
greatly appreciated i think that yes
that it can play that
that role in the sense that i think that
like anything you do if you have your
eye on the end
then you'll do whatever you're doing
better right if you
if you're making a table and you don't
have an eye on the end of the table
then you're not going to make a very
good table are you
you know if you're distracted by other
things as you're making the table and so
i think that the idea of
of of eschaton and having this notion of
end you know and the church father is
sometimes represented also as your end
like men you know remember death but
also remember the judgment like remember
judgment
that is a way to stay focused on the end
and
and then try and then you will make you
will live your life
the best way if you if you are attentive
to the end
but and so
in the sense that it can pull you out of
the lowest of lows mostly
lows in the sense of of when you're
being distracted by your passions and
you're being distracted by
by the world and by riches and by all
the crap you know that that is around us
like when you're too distracted then
focusing on the end is obviously going
to help you
to uh to to
to stop being so dispersed
so john valenzuela asked hi jonathan
what are your thoughts on the great
reset
and so far as it relates to patterns
that are playing out in the world
thanks for all you do and keep up the
good work well
i probably the thing about talking about
that on youtube is that i'm going to get
banned and my videos are going gonna get
shadow banned but i'm not gonna stop
myself completely but i
you'll notice sometimes i try to avoid
using certain words and i try to use
other words
just so that i can say what i need to
say and i'm not going to
get you know banned but
it i think that i think that the thing
we need to pay attention to
in terms of all of this it has to do
with
the the the question of systems of total
control and system of total
identification
you know and i've talked about this
before in my video on
on 666 symbolism i might make another
video on that because
um this notion of of
of the possibility of encapsulating
someone's identity
in a quantifiable way is extremely
dangerous
it is it is uh it is an extremely
destructive
act upon human nature that you can think
that you know if you look
so like schwab's one of schwab's
contentions is that
that the next decade will will
join will create something which will
fuse our
biological physical
and digital identities completely
together
and so this is impossible this is a
complete impossibility
and to try to do that is a
is a truly like satanic
gesture because you can't contain
everything
you just cannot there are no systems of
absolute control
and to try to create it is a tower of
babel
the likes of which have never existed
before
and so and especially if like
you are your identity gets swept up in
this online space
and gets swept up in in these online
systems it also means that
you can be erased from existence
and and and that that and can really
happen
like it's we've seen some glimmers of
that already and so
and it seems like it's all going in that
direction
all right so conor mitchell asked hello
mr pedro
how many questions are left man there's
a lot of ques there's a lot of questions
left
all right hello mr in your work you are
very much concerned with reviving many
of the pre-enlightenment
christian traditions of the west with it
being the 400th anniversary of the
mayflower compact i was wondering
for us ethnocentric americans if there
are any traditions and folktales of
early colonial america
or canada to appalachia old west
etcetera that you believe
have enough enough cosmological patterns
to it to be worthy of discussing
and if you would do a symbolic review of
any of them
thank you for your time and for hearing
my request i don't think i know enough
of your
folk tales so i don't really know like
i don't know what it is like i know in
canada i
i told you guys i'm just not not as much
a canadian as i am a french canadian so
i do know
a lot of uh french canadian legends and
they're
some of them are pretty are pretty
powerful a lot of them have to do with
the devil
like kind of folk catholic tales about
um the devil hiding in different
different guys
and stuff and so i'd be happy to talk
about that if you guys point out to me
which american legends are are actually
worth their salt maybe i can
i can see if they can if they can hold
up uh
when they're being analyzed i'm sorry
so hi jonathan what is the symbolism so
dorothea jonathan what is the symbolism
behind saint john the apostle resting
his head on the
chest heart of jesus i mean i think that
it's a very i think it really has to do
with
saint john's mystical function how saint
john
reveals the mystery of christ and so you
kind of have the three
three gospels that are are
are extremely important but are more
exterior in the sense that they seem to
manifest more
to talk about events and talk about
things that happen
whereas in saint john's i mean the level
of
mystical discussion that happens in the
gospel of saint john
is astounding you know i always find it
funny like i remember when i grew up
people would tell
i remember like people in my church
where i grew up would say
would tell people to read the gospel of
john first i guess because they liked
john 3 16
and they would tell people to read the
gospel of john first and i was thinking
man you should never read the gospel of
john first you should read the gospel
john
last because how could you understand
the things that
christ says in that gospel if you don't
even have a sense of who christ is
because
some of the things he says are just wild
and they're wild and we go we just like
gloss over them when he says you know i
uh
be one like i and the father and this
whole
discussion about unity between him and
the father and how he wants all that
he wants people to be one that you know
the way that he's united with the father
and the father and him
the father and them and them and the
father and it's just like this like wow
this like whole discussion of
of how god is related to us and how we
can enter into the life of god like
that is stuff that stuff is hard to deal
with um
all right hopefully that that answered
that
so the wakeful azir jonathan my friend
who you helped last month with the
question on the resurrection suffers
from extreme anger
at the people's responsible for starting
the iraq war and other wars
he longs for justin justice and
retribution
and links this desire to his protestant
upbringing
how does this longing fit into the
symbolic worldview
i lo i observe that this longing also
fuels the sjw phenomena and indeed my
friend became very political
after he'd lost his faith um
i mean i think i understand
so the thing about the thing about
christian anger
or christian frustration at
injustice is that it has to cycle
it's not it's okay to look at the world
and notice how
unjust it is and notice how people are
not um being the way they should and
and how evil people do evil things i
think that's totally fine
and i think it's important to not be
naive about that
but i think it has to always cycle back
inwards we also always have to see
how as christ told us if you hate your
brother in your heart
then that's as bad as in terms of
spiritual
effect on you it's as bad as killing
them like there's something
that there's something about
this inner examination which always
always has to be part of it
you know and and i think that that's
probably the way to deal with it is
you always have to be willing to as
you're angry with the world outside
noticing the injustice you also you
always have to kind of look back
on yourself see how you participate in
that
and see how you also hate your brother
um and that can at least maybe alleviate
a little bit of the
of the the feeling of
that you are that you have
self-righteous anger
you know
all right so radio bumpa asked matthew
make some points about about this in his
book but could you bring some more
insight
on the symbolism of sabbath maybe in
relation to the eighth day
and so the sabbath is very very
mysterious
it's a very mysterious thing about the
idea of rest and
especially in christian symbolism
there is like if you if you've ever been
to an orthodox service for
um holy saturday man the mysteries that
are in that text are just
insane like the idea that the day that
christ is in the tomb
is the sabbath like it's the holy
sabbath um
wilds it's just it just really crashes
all your categories
um and so so it shows you that there
also
is an aspect of the sabbath which is
there's an aspect of the sabbath which
is holy
and there's an affect it's a very kind
it's a very difficult
category because there's an aspect of
the sabbath which is holy
and is set apart there's an aspect of
the sabbath which is
death in the sense that it's that which
remains which shouldn't be calculated
and so that which remained which
shouldn't be calculated
is also related to the holy this is why
i
i keep telling you guys that there's a
relationship between death and glory
which is why we have martyrs which is
why we have all of this and i'm not
saying that death is
good it's not that's not the point i'm
not saying that i'm saying that there's
a
there is a relationship between the
garments of skin
and the garments of glory that they're
made of the same stuff
and that that's why a martyr
by humbly accepting death
for something higher transfers that
death
or that rest into a type of glory and so
into something holy and so that is the
mystery of the sabbath i can't
say more because man the sabbath will
just wreck your brain if you try to
think about it too much
and the the eighth day has more to do
with this
this kind of resolution in christ of
both
his death and his resurrection in his
person so the eighth day is the first
day
and the last day the day of eternity you
could say in which
the problem of the sabbath or the
question of the sabbath and this
day of rest remainder glory is
also connected to production
and and and that's what creates the holy
city
right that's what creates this this
final image of everything which
contains both the productive world
and also this this this uh
this glory which shines upon it you
could say like i'm talking in total
metaphorical terms guys and i'm sorry
if i'm sure anybody would listen to this
this would be the first time that they
hear me talk about something
will think that i'm just spouting
absolute nonsense hopefully for those
who have watched enough of my videos you
see that i'm not are trying
to talk about things that are very
difficult to think about
um
so walrus king i'm not going to ask you
sorry i'm not going to read your
question man
it's just too much uh i'll send you a
little note because it's an important
question i'll send you a little note and
we'll
talk about all right so brandon asks
what is the deal with seth the son of
adam
i've heard that there is a linguistic
connection between seth seth the
egyptian god and satan
could this say seth be related to satan
i don't think that it has anything to do
with satan really not
and i'm not sure that the set in
scripture has any etymological
relationship to
satan and even the whole set thing i
think is not
like i don't think it's totally legit
sorry i'm not totally sure that that's
legit
you know uh for all my love of the man
who who
who propounds this this uh this idea uh
seth is related to the
the the re to the rest
it's a restarting so you can understand
that if you understand the
genesis as these little cycles all the
all of genesis
is like these little cycles and so one
of the cycles
ends with uh the kane
killing abel and then kane being exiled
and then seth appears as a like a new
beginning and like a new atom
so it's like a it's like this
this uh so you can remember adam and eve
fall they get chased from the garden
and then eve gives birth to
uh to kane and kane is a new atom
and so it's like a restart and then that
falls apart
kane kills abel and that falls apart and
then there's a new beginning
with seth and then after that there's
there are other cycles which
especially the one which goes all the
way then to the flood so then
there's this relationship between two
genealogies the genealogy of seth
the genealogy of cain which are in
conflict with each other
which leads ultimately to another end
and then noah starts the game again on
the other side and so it's like these
cycles
so that's what seth so there are all
these weird traditions about seth
being let back into the garden of eden
for all these traditions about how seth
was given a branch from the tree of life
or a branch from the tree of the of
knowledge uh that he planted that he
gave passed down his lineage and was
planted by noah
like there are all these weird
traditions which are there to help you
understand
that seth plays the role of adam in a
new cycle
um that's the best way to explain it
all right so oliver erickson hey
jonathan thanks for making the silliness
of christianity tangible
what what is your view on buddhism and
how does
the notion of emptiness relate to the
christian god
i make the the silliness of christianity
tangible man
that's almost like an insult i guess um
not sure i understand that but what is
my view on buddhism
it's like i think i think buddhism
has a lot to to offer
in terms of helping you understand stuff
i think that
i think that it lacks some aspect to be
honest
uh i think the i think
for sure i think that mahayana buddhism
has
more fullness in terms of the things
that i'm talking about
and in terms of the the great chariot
and also the the idea of bodhisattvas
and this notion of bodhisattvas that
sacrifice themselves in order to then
go and get the others and so i think
that in that there's something which is
similar or akin to
the self-sacrificial love that you find
in christianity and so
i think that there are some interesting
things in buddhism um but i i do
feel like there still at least to my
sense is i still feel like there isn't
that notion of
this just total joining of heaven and
earth there's rather
this desire to kind of ascend
and leave behind you know the
illusory aspects of reality but if you
this idea of illusion is is a problem
it's like
the the notion of illusion every time
someone tells me that something is an
illusion
i always like think it's an illusion so
if it's an illusion it's an illusion of
what
like for something to be an illusion
there needs to be something
there needs to be something behind it
which it's
it's an illusion of and so i i really
struggle with
with some of those aspects um
and so i think that for example like
like i've read the thing about buddhism
it's so why too it's like but i have
read sometimes where
the notion of emptiness in buddhism is
formulated in a way
which seems to not deny
the relative reality of all the
different layers of
of manifestation and so when i see that
kind of stuff i'm like okay
this is better like at least in my
understanding but
yeah i still think that it doesn't
it doesn't offer uh it just it doesn't
offer what what christ offered but i but
but it's
there's definitely like
you know i i'd take a buddhist over a
new atheist any day
all right um all right so
jan peter jager asked among
western painters there was the lion and
color debate
what would be according to an orthodox
approach from iconography to this
question
um i mean the line in color debate
i think it just it just has it's just
the general
problem of opposites it's just a one
manifestation of these
of the the tendency we have or the
inevitability we have
to organize the world in terms of
opposites
and so you know i
i think that you can transpose the color
line debate in
in the history of iconography you can
you can definitely find
painters that paint more from within
towards the line
and then some painters that paint more
from the line towards the color
uh and and so there's a tendency to
marginalize
the line in some traditions and then
some tendency to
mark to see color just as a filling in
of lines right
uh and so i think that definitely you
can see
and you could probably understand it in
the left right type of symbolism
you know with the importance of limits
whereas the importance of
of a kind of improvisation you know
that's probably something that you could
understand
you could understand some of the history
of iconography related to
these types of opposites you could say
um all right so i think i'm done
with the questions it's like these q and
a's keep getting longer and longer and
you know what's going on with that all
right let me check to see
i think i did see some some uh super
chats go
in there and so it's getting late though
all right okay so i see
that yes there are some wow there's
quite a few
all right let's see if i can get through
them quickly
um all right so honest joe biden
no it doesn't start there it doesn't
start with honest joe biden start with
andre johnson
uh so uh
what do you so andre johnson says what
do you think is interesting
in the legends of charlemagne and his
peers
one of the the things that i find
interesting in the
in the legend of charlemagne is just how
superhuman he comes out in a lot of
these
legends you know like if you read the
if you read the uh the the the the
song of roland for example it's like
charlemagne
is it looks like this old god that is
like
it was like hundreds of years old and is
like this gritty
uh almost you know
like inhuman almost like in human
character and so
i just i just like the fact that
people are capable of kind of telling
those stories and so
that's probably like the song of roland
probably obviously and i'm just being
cliche here because obviously probably
my favorite legend in terms of uh of
charlemagne
um you know and how it manifests this
this relationship to the outsider you
know
and also like in the legend of
charlemagne you really get like a
like an interesting vision of the
outsider
you know the the saracens and how
they're caricatured but
if you go if you if you understand the
caricature as
as this inevitable projection into the
other
you know and understanding this
inevitable kind of
monstrous presentation of the other then
you can kind of understand it and
there's something about
the way that that they're presented that
can help you understand the process
itself of how we view strange things and
how they
present themselves to us so that's
probably one of the most interesting
things i find in the legends of
charlemagne
but they're not as good as arthurian
legend i mean that's probably why also
they've been mostly discarded all right
so anna jobine what does he ask
so why does my luck seem to be so
inordinately
bad come on you just won the the you
just won
the presidency i your luck is probably
you probably
i'm not gonna say anything about your
election americans all right
okay so my personality seems to be quite
winning at times i'll be albeit i am a
bit of a contrarian but it doesn't add
up
it shouldn't be this bad what the
f is going on feels metaphysical i mean
i don't know it's possible
you know when things go bad for us it's
it's probably
usually a time for us to re-examine our
priorities no matter what the reason
for it is for for things to go bad for
us um
you know so sorry i don't know i don't
know
so matt asked what do you think of
eastern catholicism and
you're trying to give me trouble here
for five dollars he have they
successfully integrated west and east
are they trying to tie together two
things that do not fit so i would say
that eastern catholicism is playing
is is
is playing the role of the margin it's
playing the role of an in-between
category for the positive and negative
aspects that that has
which means that on the one hand it will
always
be seen it will always be in danger of
being seen as a compromise from both
sides
it will be seen from the side of the
catholics
as a possible bridge to get the orthodox
into their thing
uh but if there's ever a true union
between east and west and i don't mean
like a fake
you know fake uh compromise union but an
actual true
union of communion which would happen
through a mutual
understanding of the the divides and
the reconciliation of the theological
divides and ecclesia
ecclesiological divides then the
then those eastern catholics would play
a central role
in making that happen so that's what i
think
and i have sympathy for people who go
that direction i just i
definitely have sympathy for them
because you know
yeah it's not easy our options are not
easy
folks it's the end of the world what are
you gonna do
all right paul vander clay hey paul
that's awesome never done a super chat
before i just want to support jonathan
and his channel
it's good to see you paul i don't know
if you're still around it's it's we've
been going at this for a long time
you know um i didn't watch your video
paul made a video about my discussion
with
uh rationality rules today so i have to
watch that
um watch it tomorrow i will definitely
do that tomorrow
so it's good to see you so matt w asks
uh charlemagne named his sword
was it to incarnate the happy warrior
archetype i think that it definitely has
something to do with that
uh there is something about so yeah are
certain sword styles cruciform
for symbolic reasons i think that i
think that
old i think that at the beginning they
def probably
necessarily at least not consciously but
i definitely
think that as christianity developed
then that image of the cross and the
sword
uh definitely that symbolism could not
be avoided and so they became
joined in very strange and contradictory
ways if you think about it but
nonetheless like you can't avoid it um
and i think that charlemagne did
embody that if you when you read the
things about charlemagne he did seem
like a really impressive character like
he
you know he would he he would like to i
mean some of it's not great like he was
obviously had many many women
and he he would you know he would like
hang out in hot baths like he'd love to
take hot baths with people and he would
have all this meeting
in these like kind of spas where he
would hang out with his
aristocracy he was definitely a
character man
all right so the sid asks hygienic to
explain the symbolism of smoking
cigarettes or a pipe also any tips
for someone looking to start carving
that's an interesting question because
there definitely is a difference
between a cigarette and a pipe there's
something
aristocratic about a pipe for sure and
then there's something
about egalitarian about the cigarette
and
even in the whole aesthetic that the
cigarette was used as
there's something industrial about the
cigarette
and egalitarian and the pipe has
something i think maybe also because the
pipes were
carved or handmade or have a have
cigarettes are throw away like you just
throw them away whereas pipes have a
uh they have this artistic quality to
them or they're made by an artisan
and and so they have a a more
yeah there's something aristocratic
about them i can't totally explain it
i'm being
totally intuitive about this um
so stephen anderson for 420 oh the sid
get 70 czars i don't know what those are
are
so um steven edison usd 420 my
evolutionary psychology made me give you
money
that's hilarious yeah that's hilarious
all right so the new guy for 1999 usd
says can you do an in-depth video on the
symbolism and nature of the force and if
it would be considered a sort of deity
suggests the existence of a supreme
deity or just an amalgam of religious
philosophical ideas i think
that's it's really interesting because
the force
at first was trying to represent a kind
of pantheistic uh
general non-personal spiritual
like energy or whatever they call it so
it was
always super new age from the beginning
um
and and then it morphed into like these
midichlorians or whatever these like
these like microscopic beings that that
and so it's really
it's really great because it's really
the opposite of anything spiritual
it's really the op it's like it really
is a kind of
if a materialist could come up with a
religion it's the force
like because it's medichlorians it's
like this
physically you can find these physical
little creatures that
are acting like together in a kind of
what is it like a midichlorian democracy
here i don't know what how it works
but it just i just i'm sorry sorry to
mock star wars guys i know
you all love star wars i like star wars
too but the the the midichlorian thing
just is
uh it just it just blew it for me when
that happened
um so bobby joe says i'm a mormon and
your discussions and videos that
significantly brought in my
understanding
that my friends just wanted to say
thanks to for all you do well thanks
bobby joe
little saigon uh for five dollars says
did you see sam harris officially left
the idw
over certain members entertaining the
possibility of voter fraud yeah whatever
the idw you guys know i never
identified with that i never identified
with the idw
um but it's okay
all right guys i think i think i think
we're done
um
i think we're done and so why thanks for
thanks for uh thanks for coming out guys
and uh
these are getting longer and longer
maybe one day i'll be
able to last for three hours like joe
rogan of some kind
and so it was good to talk to everybody
happy that everybody
showed up and i will see you guys
next month so bye-bye